[Music]
we are in the midst of I think what
pretty much everybody is saying is the
craziest election at least in modern
times as a true outsider who made it
through the [ __ ] you got through the
system ran on the Reform Party ticket 99
became governor of Minnesota what do you
make of just before we get into the two
of them what do you just make of the
state of the system at the moment well
the system is broken and the system is
based upon the concept of bribery where
if you if you do bribery in the private
sector you go to jail but in in our
political system it's the status quo you
want an audience with the candidate a
democrat or republican you better bring
a check with you and you better donate
to their campaign otherwise they they're
not talking to you and so it's a system
of bribery and the people who thrive in
a system like bribery have to be crooked
to begin with because if you're
comfortable in a bribery system then
obviously you're comfortable breaking
laws and bending rules and doing
whatever it takes and so that's really I
think what's wrong as a whole with our
system today the Democrats and
Republicans have turned it into a
complete system of bribery yeah when you
look back on the fact that you actually
won as a third party candidate in
Minnesota does that does it almost seem
crazy to you now because it really seems
that at this point we've we've gone so
far backwards now that I don't know that
someone could do it anymore
well you can do it it could be done this
year if they'd allow Gary Johnson the
key is the debates mm-hmm see the Dems
and république
they sing Kumbaya with each other when
it's time to keep jill's dr. Stein and
Gary governor Johnson out of the debates
they're right in bed together on that
baby but
but the point is they don't let anyone
else into the game as Ralph Nader called
that the two-party dictatorship that's
what you have in this country the
two-party dictatorship and they they
won't let anyone else in for fear that a
third entity like I was in Minnesota
will beat them and then oh my god what
do they do then right
so no if they get beat yeah so speaking
of getting beat I mean Hillary beat
Bernie but we know that the d-ends own
she cheated right so we know the DNC was
in on it so god the DMZ it was fixed it
was fixed Bernie wasn't gonna win they
got super della and the minute I heard
about super-delegates I said what are
these things that's the facts so the fix
was in Bernie didn't have a chance
Hillary was gonna win and they fit in
who did they blame the Russians they
blame they blame a messenger not the
message if they hadn't wrote those
emails could anyone have hacked them
no they wrote them and then how do they
know the Russians did it wasn't that
convenient let's blame the Russians are
the Russians that concerned over whether
Hillary or Trump win it doesn't matter
because it's the same Democrats and
Republicans are gonna be running the
thing anyway it sounds like the
beginning of a plot of a movie that you
should have been in in like 87 and then
you and Schwarzenegger go in there and
clean up [ __ ] maybe I don't know you
know when you look at it from that
aspect it is it's almost laughable like
a movie script but you know the whole
situation is they won't let anyone else
in the game for fear the rise of a third
party the third choice and this is the
year should happen because Trump and
Hillary's negatives are through the
ceiling yeah nobody likes either one of
them so do you why did they vote for a
men when you have other candidates why
would you vote for people you don't even
like yeah so do you think the real
missed opportunity here then was that
instead of Bernie just acquiescing and
and sort of being put down by by Hillary
in the DNC that
he should be the third party guy right
now I get it with Carrie Johnson I did a
video a couple weeks ago saying we have
to at least support this guy until the
debates because we need another voice in
there but do you think Bernie actually
missed his moment here yeah and I knew
what was gonna happen because last
summer Bernie came to Minnesota and I
went down there and I actually went down
there
thinking I would endorse him he gave me
the complete cold shoulder really
oh he he spoke to me in a hallway for
one minute and I all I got to ask him
was the important question I said
senator Sanders if you failed to defeat
Hillary Clinton for the Democratic
nomination will you keep the revolution
going by either running as an
independent or throw your support to an
independent he looked me right in the
eye and said nope I will endorse Hillary
right there I said he's a phony
because he's a Democrat and for him to
now mask himself as an independent is
phony Bernie Sanders is a Democrat
because once he said he'd endorse
Hillary Clinton no matter what that made
him a Democrat in my book he wouldn't
even go outside he wouldn't continue the
movement so all those people out there
that endorsed and got so behind Bernie
Sanders you got hoodwinked yeah and
those look great those people are not
excited to vote for Hillary so let's
talk about Hillary for a second I mean
from everything that you've said here
and everything that I know that you
believe about money and politics and a
corrupt system and politicians that lie
in a media that helps them lie it
strikes me that Hillary is the pinnacle
of that so is she I mean do you view her
as actually a real threat to the
underpinnings of what democracy is
supposed to be uh yeah because it's all
fixed or it proved with the emails that
the whole democratic process was fixed
that they hand-picked her and it didn't
matter what went on she was going to be
the nomination yeah and and she you know
she takes a half a million dollars to do
a speech for Wall Street that's not
buying her right he can sit and say that
she's not influenced that insults my
intelligence right truly does I'm pretty
sure and the fact that she here's the
most important thing to me the most
important vote Hillary Clinton ever took
as a senator she admits she blew it she
voted for the Iraq war and now she says
that was a mistake
so sending our kids to war the most
important vote you could possibly take
as a politician Hillary got it wrong and
admits to it now so we're gonna put her
thumb on the button yeah and by the way
whatever you think of Benghazi
specifically she was Secretary of State
for what we've done in Libya and now all
hell has broken loose over there too so
there's a there's a series of bad
decisions I'm curious do you give any of
the people that voted for Iraq do you
give any of them a little bit of a leash
because of the way we now know that the
information that the intelligence
community told them things that weren't
true you know Colin Powell with uh with
the rods you don't buy any of that I was
doing the right-wing radio talk show
host once when I was governor and the
subject came up and this guy said it's a
difficult decision not the hardest
decision you could make as an elected
official to go to war hmm I looked at
him and said you're wrong it's an easy
decision and he jumped all over me how
can you say it's an easy decision to go
to war when he was done I told him why
and I'll tell you why going to war is an
easy decision here's why a war is
justified if you're willing to send your
kids to fight it hmm if you ain't
willing to send your kids how do you
send someone else's and I can
unequivocally tell you I would not have
sent my kids to Iraq
yeah and that's as simple as it gets
it's justified if you're willing to send
your children to fight it and if you're
not willing to do that how do you send
someone else's kids to do it sure and
and we always have money to do it even
though we
now don't have money to fix our
infrastructure and our roads and all
that so all right let's let's put Hilary
aside now and let's move to Trump I'm
gonna partly put some put some words in
your mouth to preface this I have a
feeling that you kinda like Trump that
just on the outsider part of it the
wrestling part of it the the breaking
the system getting through the [ __ ]
saying it things off the top of your
head for that portion of it I'm gonna
say that you're a pro trunk absolutely
yeah and I like what he's done I like
he's fractured the Republican Party just
as I liked it when Bernie fractured the
Democrats remember something Pat
Buchanan and the Republicans destroyed
the Reform Party when they came in a 98
or 2000 Pat Buchanan brought his minions
in and they had a mistake in the Reform
Party you could become a same-day
delegate so he brought in all his people
got the nomination took 30 million of
our dollars and never even ran guest who
watched all that Donald Trump because
Donald Trump came and supported me and a
soda in 98 Donald ain't a Republican
he's an independent right he just joined
the Republicans like Bernie joined the
Democrats well Trump watched Pat
Buchanan and destroy the Reform Party he
essentially now did the same thing to
them right back in their face he came in
and destroyed their party of what it
used to be so I cheer him for that now
I've known Donald for 25 years I
consider him a friend but will I support
him no because we've differ completely
on the Middle East
I'm anti-war get out of there they're
gonna go to war no matter which one of
these two people you elect four years
from now we're still gonna be at war but
having said that I also differ with
Donald on immigration I live in Mexico
half the year I love Mexicans they're
wonderful people I don't want to live in
East Berlin we're gonna put a wall up
excuse me
Ronald Reagan is the is the icon of the
modern-day Republican right he might
only supposed to be
well I don't think Ronald Reagan could
even be a Republican today but that
aside it seems to me his iconic quote
was mr. Gorbachev tear down this wall
what is he thinking today knowing the
United States is possibly gonna build a
wall and that we're gonna become East
Berlin so so putting the walls I made
off oh yeah here's your trade off if
we're gonna then we should take down the
Statue of Liberty there you go there's
the Statue of Liberty says send us your
poor send us your downtrodden and all
that well we obviously don't want them
so let's take down the Statue of Liberty
it's outdated today right I mean isn't
that the whole point of immigration
usually countries don't send you there
their brightest and their and their best
but it's the people that need help and
that's why most of our ancestors came
here it'll who come here for to make
their way to go after the American dream
you can become yours an immigrant and
end up a millionaire the opportunities
there yeah so so I'm with you on on all
of that and and I've said many times I
don't know if the wall is sensible or
financially sound or any and that's a
wait I'll tell you how sensible it is
yeah you build a 30-foot wall and I'll
find somebody with a 31 foot ladder so
it's good for the ladder people to know
no it does work though you want to know
how I know it works because centuries
ago they built the Great Wall of China
and there ain't one Mexican that I know
of that I know that is a good point
that's I can't think of job would have
to go by I would have to google that
after and find out what's what so I know
a certain amount of people are gonna
hear you and they're gonna say wait a
minute mentor wants open borders and
blah blah blah what would you say about
because you also don't trust the
government so it puts your position in
an interesting spot because I would I'm
with you but then it comes - all right
well how do we vet people properly and I
don't trust that the government will do
it properly or knows how to do it
properly or even can do it
properly well governments about
compromising so I'll give you my
compromise okay hmm you have to bring
home and close our hundred and
seventy-eight military bases throughout
the world and bring our kids home and
then use our military to protect our
border I heard an interview where a BBC
guy was grilling President Putin of
Russia Vladimir Putin and he was really
getting on him about Russia's aggression
and Putin very calmly said to him well
let's really talk about this openly
Russia has two military bases outside of
the country of Russia the United States
I believe has something like a hundred
and seventy-eight who's the aggressor
yeah I mean Bill Maher says it all the
time it's like we still have 40,000
troops are saying stationed in Germany
the war is over the war is over and the
point is who's the aggressor yeah we
accused Russia of being aggressive I
would shine the mirror on us and say
were the aggressors 178 bases throughout
the world for what bring them home close
them down so if enough like the rest of
the country defend themselves
yeah so if enough people heard that
message how do you actually do it cuz I
think a lot of people hear the spirit of
what you're saying and say yeah it
doesn't make sense to do all this stuff
but how do you actually untie all of
this stuff well Ron Paul I remember when
Congressman Paul was opposed to the Iraq
war and they said well we're already in
there how can we get out now and I
thought Congressman Paul had the
greatest dancer in the world
he said we marched in all we have to do
is turn around and march out yeah but do
we bear some responsibility then because
although I obviously was whoa well like
for example so when we went into Iraq
originally by the time Obama had us pull
out it was doing better they were having
free elections and all that then we we
left in a haste and now it's basically a
war zone again so it's like we're damned
if we do it we're damned if we don't we
got in
and then we left in a messy way and now
it's worse okay
Jessie's gonna give you the lesson on
the Middle East now Freya brother I I
spoke once and I had a woman come up to
me after Muslim and as Bill Maher said
she was decked out in the beekeepers
suit right but her face wasn't covered
but she had up all the Muslim attire
young woman she walked up to me when I
was done speaking and she said to me
this
she said you understand the Middle East
why doesn't anyone else here and now I'm
gonna explain it to you what you have in
the Middle East today is blowback it is
blowback from colonialism you have to go
way back to man when Europe colonial
eyes the whole world and went through
that when they got to the Middle East
they made the countries to benefit them
the Europeans they didn't make the
countries to benefit the people who live
there you had three warring factions
there the Shiites the Kurds and the
Sunnis rather than giving them all their
own country they put all three of them
in every country yeah so the wars
continued on and on inside the borders
of the countries so the only way the
countries could be governed was by a
dictator the minute then the United
States comes along and decides we're
gonna remove the dictators and give them
democracy people who wouldn't know
democracy if it bit him on the ass we
take out the dictators and what do you
have now total chaos and total
disruption of the entire region and when
will the United States look in the
mirror and take ownership for what's
gone on over there but we don't bare the
ownership do we Isis exists because of
what we did we went into Iraq and you
got Bush and Cheney who never went to
war running the OP right well anybody
with any knowledge will tell
you you don't disband the military like
we did we put him in unemployment right
Bremer went over there and kicked them
out the door well they then went up and
formed and became Isis if you invade
someone you keep the military intact
because it's a strange thing with
military military will follow who's ever
in charge that way you've got the whole
Iraqi army is still on the payroll they
can feed their families they're gonna do
what you want them to do instead George
Bush and Dick Cheney and Bremer cut them
loose
yeah now we won't take responsibility we
created Isis look if you want one other
example of that it's that we have a
military dictatorship now after they
tried democracy in Egypt and it's one of
the only stable places governor I know
you have to go so real quick who is
winning this election I want the
official prediction right now well I
figure Hillary probably because it's
fixed you know well her nomination was
fixed why wouldn't you believe the rest
of the elections gonna be fixed the same
way we shall see all right well it's
always a pleasure talking to governor I
know you got a long game press ahead of
you so I want to thank Governor Jesse
Ventura for joining me on the show this
week and you guys can check out his new
book the marijuana manifesto Jesse
Ventura is marijuana manifesto in the
link that is right down below thanks
again governor
[Music]
you